I can't explain why
I shine and no one else on I think
everybody shines and different things
and a lot of things I can't do I can't
play basketball like every other black
person in America but I can act I'm not
a go to that truce by myself because I'm
there every day I could be me I could be
whoever because I'm true to me I can go
to neutral easily a lot of people black
white Mexican young or old fat or skin
you have a problem being true to their
self they have a problem looking in the
mirror and looking directly into their
own Souls the reason I sells six million
records the reason I can go to jail and
come out without a scratch the reason I
can walk around the reason I am lying
today is because I can look directly
into my face and find my soul there it's
not sold I didn't sell it it's still
with Benny I still feel it
my heart is still connected to my body
so I could any character i'ma bring that
intensity that truth and honesty two of
them so there's not really tricky
everybody can do it if they just can go
to that spot I guess all the things that
happen to me in my life
allow me to go there easier if I know in
this hotel room they have food every day
and I'm knocking on the door every day
to eat and they tell and they open the
door let me see the party
let me see like them throwing salami all
over that but I mean just like throwing
food around or you're telling me there's
no food in there
you know I'm saying every day I'm
standing outside trying to sing my way
in you know I'm saying we are hungry
please let us in we are pleased that I
said after about a week that song is
gonna change the we hungry we need some
food after two three weeks it's like you
know give me a little dragon on the door
after year you just like you know I'm
saying I'm picking a lot coming through
the door blast so now what do you think
we're gonna do and my raps that I'm
rapping to my community the media they
don't talk about it so I my raps I have
to talk about it you just watched two
amazing clips of Tupac Shakur take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]